hey matthew hey rachel good morning
hey
so i am the biggest she's all flat fan
so pumped that you guys are in this and
i really liked the film too for someone
who's such a die-hard fan of the
original i was so happy with this um
rachel is a little what we were hoping
for like exactly
like our version who are who say yes we
will go on the journey with you to the
new one that's awesome thank you
that was the first review i've heard
that was the first that was awesome you
thank you yeah you just gave us the
first
review
no way well yeah i mean i think when a
film is like sacred to so many people
you're like okay let's give this a shot
and then i was like oh wow this is
awesome
so rachel is it a bit wild to you you
know you're on the set of he's all that
a reimagining of a film that you started
over 20 years ago did it feel a little
surreal
it felt really
really surreal
but then pretty quickly and i don't know
what it says about my ego that this is
where i landed but i decided that the
whole thing was like a gigantic
compliment
yes i think
i don't you should see it that way no
but it's like hey you know what people
liked our movie enough that they're like
yeah we could probably still make a lot
of money off that like yeah let's just
let's just make more of that i know that
we want to make it yeah let's invite
rachel cook back because that is the
worst oh yeah so that's so well anyway i
don't know about that but but yeah maybe
that's just the story i had to tell
myself to not feel um ancient but it
felt really it felt really really good
to be there and to be a be an active
supportive of that
yeah absolutely you know matthew is so
fun seeing your character show some
dance moves lebron hudson style i've
always wanted to know
did you choreograph the original
sequence from she's all back give it to
me baby dance sequence or was that all
improv no there was um
i'm gonna in between this i'm gonna
remember who it was that i did the scene
with that choreographed the first scene
but the um
that we worked on it for a week so that
whole sequence in the in the first movie
we worked on for a week and like in the
studio and i dance teachers teaching me
how to do it and then taking the set
that day
was probably one of the most terrifying
days i've ever had we were all told
matthew wants to practice with no one
around for you know for a couple times
give him his space and i was like what's
going on it's like horrible there's 150
people sitting there and all of a sudden
you're like dancing like an idiot and it
was very embarrassing
and it was like you know you no but
that's a really good dance
they don't just randomly ask you to do
that like they don't want anybody to do
that it's true
but i'm a good dancer for a guy that
doesn't dance
but like dooley hills in the first movie
he's like an incredible dancer he used
to dance like just yes and like in this
movie and he's all that like all the
people that do the dancing with are all
watching the whole sequence you're like
oh i feel like a total idiot because i
feel either you feel like a poser but
look at the end of the day it was a
moment where in the first movie i was
super proud of how it came out it was
like you know a moment in my career that
i look back on and um
you know it's it's
the man that you were then and it's like
a touchstone to your career and so it
was nice to come back it was humbling to
be a part of the new one
and um i you know i
i don't know it was i'm glad it came out
okay can you can i actually ask i forgot
to ask you like how do you feel having
like a the jordan you you read the
script like the jordan van drain
character is this sort of yeah
ridiculous idiot yeah who's sort of
supposed to like show he's supposed to
be like kind of a mirror of your
character back then yeah did you my
character back then was not nearly as
gorgeous as he is i mean
here's the thing about the cast they are
all beautiful they're all super talented
stupid beautiful they're you know the
the great thing about the script is that
it totally works and they all embody
those characters in a really wonderful
way at the end of the day the movie is
an homage to the original but it's its
own little piece of
cinematic love i mean it's really really
really lovely
well said guys so nice getting to talk
to you i got the wrap but i have to tell
you yeah so happy you both were in this
film thanks so much